i'm going to multiply 78 times 65 in a
little less than standard way but
hopefully it'll make some sense and
you'll realize that there's multiple
ways that you can multiply and this is
actually the way that i multiply numbers
in my head so 78 times 65 and then we're
actually going to think about what the
different parts of this process
represent on this area model so 78 times
60
65.
so i'm going to start just the way we
normally start when we multiply i'm
going to start with this 5 in this one's
place and i'm going to say 5 times 8 is
40. instead of just writing a 0 and
carrying a 4 right over here i'm just
going to write the number 40. so this
was the 5 times the 8. now i'm going to
multiply the 5 times the seven
and we have to be a little bit careful
here because five times this isn't just
any seven this is a seventy so what is
five times seventy well five times seven
would be thirty five so five times
seventy is three hundred fifty so i'll
write that down 350.
so just as review 5 times 8 is 40. 5
times 7 is 350. if you add these two
together this is going to be 5 times 78
now let's go over to the six
so let's multiply the six times the
eight now we have to be careful again
this six is not just a regular six it's
in the tens place this is a sixty
sixty times eight well 6 times 8 is 48
so 60 times 8 is going to be 480
480. so it's going to be 480.
and then 6 times 7 well that would be 42
but we have to be careful this is 60
times 70. so we're going to have two
zeros at the end this is 4 200 not just
42. so 6 times 7
is 4200
4200
and now we can add everything together
and this is a very similar process to
what we do when we do the traditional
method of multiplying i just made a
little bit more explicit what parts are
from what are from what multiplying
which digits but we can add everything
together in the ones place we have a
zero in the tens place we have four plus
five is nine nine plus eight is
seventeen
and now we can carry a one
one plus three is four four plus four is
eight eight plus two is ten
carry a one you say regroup or one even
and you have a five right over there so
you get five thousand seventy now i
wanna think about i wanna visualize what
was going on here using this area model
so once again we had 78 so i'm going to
make this vertical length represent 78
so this distance right over here
this distance right over here represents
the 70.
that's the 70 and then we'll make this
distance right over here
represent the eight let me make that a
little bit cleaner so you see what i'm
talking about so this distance right
over here
represents the eight and then we're
gonna multiply that times 65 so this
distance right over here
i i it's not drawn perfectly to scale
but it gives the idea this is 60 and
then
this distance right over here
this distance right over here
is the five so this whole distance is 65
this entire distance is 78. so when you
multiply a six if you had a rectangle
that's 68 you or 65 units wide and you
multiplied it and it had a height of 78
units then its area is going to be 78
times 65 its area is going to be 5070.
now each of these parts we can map to
one part of this of this area model
right over here when we multiplied the 5
times the 8 and got the 40
that was that was this section right
over here 5
times 8 is equal to 40.
when we multiplied 5 times 70 and got
350 that's this right over here 5
times 70 and we got 350.
when we multiplied 60 the 6 in the tens
place 60 times 8 and got 480 that's this
right over here this is 60 times 8 is
equal to 480
and then finally when we multiplied
60 times 70
and got 4200 that's this area right over
here this area is 60 wide 70 tall so
this is 60
times 70 which is equal to 4200 and then
when we added everything up to get 5070
we were essentially just adding up the
areas of each of these tiles this big
one is 4200 that makes up most of the
area then we get 480 from this magenta
one then 350 from this kind of greenish
yellow one and then 40 from this
greenish blue one to get 5070. so the
area of this entire thing is 5070 square
units